so first demo I'm going to is a demo
with the Raspberry Pi and a Geiger
counter so the setup here is a a
Raspberry Pi of course running the
Wolfram language the Raspberry Pi is
connected to a Geiger counter from
sparkfun company which is over here and
the communication happens over a serial
communication so you do I'll show you in
a script real quick how it works but
first I want to just kind of show you
since this is up and running and I don't
want to press my luck too much so at the
moment it's using a scheduled task to
basically accumulate count the number of
hits that the Chi kurt geiger counter
has and you can see this little green
line hit green light here that's the
counter of the number of radioactive hit
so right now I got this this watch that
i got from tails graze cabinet of
curiosities a lot of scary things in
there but if i take it if i take that
you know away then it just goes to zero
or sometimes there will be one blip
right and so you can kind of see that
you know the Geiger counter you know it
basically works if I if I stick it right
in front of there and just right so now
it's sitting right in front of this
copper tube which is actually doing the
you know the counting you know I'll show
you the script in just a second let me
just do the the other thing which is
much more radioactive it's a piece of I
don't want to touch it for too long but
people ate from these things it's called
fiestaware and apparently this was a
popular dish to eat from in the 1930s so
you could see that that watch it goes up
to about 120 if you stick it really
close so let's see what you know what
this goes up to
okay so that goes to group that goes
through 251 as you can see in it you
know they did that come out I just want
to show you a script real quick you know
how this works so so real quick you open
a serial port with device open in the
case of Raspberry Pi the device name is
used be zero and you have to set the
baud rate that the you know manufacturer
specified here then the visor read
buffer basically reads everything out of
the buffer you said some you know it's
at t0 in the Delta is five seconds print
out the table then you run a scheduled
task every five seconds which is T Delta
and then every five seconds you you know
you print out the the current time and
the count so you read you do a device
read buffer off from the cereal again
and you count the number of 49 s because
that's the character code for one and it
that's how it comes with us that's where
that number 49 comes from ok d I think
I'm going to leave it at that so because
we've got Ian coming up next and he's
going to do a demo with an Arduino and a
force you know like a Newton meter what
do you call it what do you call it a
force sensor ok all right thank you
hello everyone my name is ian johnson
and i will be presenting how to use in
arduino and specifically a vernis a
force sensor with the Wolfram language
in Mathematica and so here is a live
plot of a reading from this sensor as we
as we manipulate it basically so as you
can see is if we push and pull on the
sensor these these readings are taken
from the Arduino and their foot right in
mathematica for us and so i'll click
explain what an Arduino is an Arduino is
a small hobbyist electronics platform
that you can use to hook up to all sorts
of hardware devices you can hook it up
to motors sensors LEDs you know all
sorts of physical hardware things and so
now using my drivers you can use all of
you know the physical hardware world
that is the Arduino you can use it all
with in Mathematica and I think it's
pretty cool one of the cool things about
their do we know is that it's an open
source platform and so there's lots and
lots of work that lots and lots of
people have done on building various
shields like for example we're using the
spark fund Bernier interface shield here
you can get lots of other shields that
people have built and there are
libraries written for these shields that
you know people there's a lot of work
that has been put into various things
for this so it's powering my arduino
driver is what's called the device
framework the device framework is a new
feature to Mathematica 10 it's a
basically a standardized set of commands
like device open twice read device
configure etc that can be used with many
many devices and specifically here we're
using it with the Arduino and so here
I'm going to read from the Varni a
Arduino object and so that's the voltage
on analog pin zero and that's the
digital state of in two and here i can
go and i can write a value of one to
turn the LED on and i can write a value
of zero to turn it off and so we can do
other cool things we can here's a
vertical gauge of of the force sensor
you can see that so there are lots of
once you get this data into mathematica
you can do all sorts
things like it one cool device framework
function here is the device read time
series and so for the next two seconds
it'll take data readings and we can go
and we can plot that or with all this
kind of boring straight line nothing
moved in two seconds but all of the cool
time series functions that you know you
can actually use as with live data that
you collect right in time Mathematica
and so another cool thing about my
driver firmware is that with this device
configure you can configure the Arduino
to have various functions that you that
you write yourself like custom functions
written in C or C++ you can upload those
to the Arduino turn that off quick and
then i'll upload that and so what what
this basically enables you do is write
any kind of Arduino function you know
here we're going to blinking LED but you
can obviously do much more complicated
hardware things you know upload that
that will be on the Arduino and now with
device execute we can now execute that
device so as you can hopefully see the
little blue LED flashes for a very very
short amount of time so a future feature
of this will be the translation of
Wolfram language code into Arduino code
so you'll be able to write these
functions in in the Wolfram language to
be uploaded the Arduino so as I was
saying before there are lots and lots of
work they've been put into building
these libraries and the shields for the
Arduino and so for example there's the
servo the servo library for controlling
servos or there's here's a handwritten
library that I wrote myself LED blinks
an LED for Morse code or here's the
vernis a library but you can upload all
these libraries to be used with the
Arduino so what this basically allows
you to do is if you have a shield or
hardware device it's very easy to plug
it into the Arduino and then in
Mathematica you can write up a quick
little driver that uses that library to
interface with it so here what i've done
is i've written a smartphone Bernier
interface shield driver and so I've
already opened the driver so I don't
need to do that but so we can read here
and so what what sorry
cool about this specific driver is with
Bernier sensors the Arduino can pull the
sensor to actually see what kind of
sensors attached so here we can see this
is a dual range force sensor which is on
the 50 Newton calibration range and we
can here we can see it's he has units of
Newton's as reported by the sensor we
can see what the calibration data is the
coloration equation type intercept blah
blah blah all of that all of that is
automatically gotten from the sensor and
so if I would plug in a different sensor
all of this would change and all of the
device read options would would change
and reflect that so here we're going to
push on the sensor really hard to show
that it maxes out at about 50 50 Newtons
so there you can see oh I guess it goes
up to 60 Newton's but so you can see if
we were to change it to 10 it would
change change to 10 Newton's basically
as maximum there we can see the units or
yeah so so it's really cool because it
uses the calibration data to determine
the unit for us and so we can use all of
the units functions in Mathematica so
for example if we want to convert that
to pounds here's you know almost zero
Newton's in pounds but it has all these
units built into it and so it's really
useful for stuff like science
experiments because you know units are
built right into it and so what we're
going to do last is we're going to
calculate the coefficient of friction
between the new kind of science book and
a table okay so what we're basically
going to do is we'll read from the
sensor using device read time series as
we very slowly increase the force with
which we pull on the book so in the next
20 seconds it will be gathering data
basically as we pull on it and the
maximum of that will be the maximum
friction force that's given off and that
will we'll use that to calculate the
coefficient of friction so once that
quick finishes here we'll do a list line
plot of that and have a quick look at
the tab okay so here so we can see well
it kind of goes off the screen here I'm
not sure why list line plot isn't
working but if I go
the range 20 maybe yep there we go so we
can see it maxes out around oh that
looks like about 10 10 Newtons but let's
let's calculate what the actual maximum
is so if you take the max of the force
data against its 9.85 Newton's is the
maximum so now what we're going to do is
now we're going to measure how much it
weighs and so we'll pick up the book
very carefully obviously and we'll
re-evaluate this to measure how much it
weighs so as we measure that soon as
this finishes evaluating but the maximum
there will basically be the weight of
the book in Newtons and if we remember
correctly the the coefficient of
friction is defined as the ratio between
the maximum visit the maximum friction
force and the normal force basically so
the normal force is going to be equal to
the weight so we can take the max of
this again and so here's our normal
force that's 25 Newtons and here's our
resistance force this 9.85 Newtons so
we'll divide those two and we get 0.32
as our as our coefficient friction so
thank you very much
hi my name is Tom sure
I work here at Wolfram research and in
addition to working in the user
interface department I also in my
copious spare time I like to do
astronomy when I get the chance and so
of course one of the things that I've
been doing is seeing how Mathematica can
make my astronomy hobby even easier and
more rewarding and one of the great
things about Mathematica in addition to
being a powerful computational tool is
it has a lot of data built into it and
that was one of the things that we're
promoting in these later versions
mathematic one of the things that
Mathematica has in particular is
astronomical data and and you can easily
access this and make use of it so
thinking about that and thinking that I
like to run my telescope I use the
recently introduced serial connectivity
package in Mathematica 10 to write a
telescope control package and the
telescope control package will run on
any version of Mathematica because all
it requires is a serial port for
instance it will run on the version of
Mathematica that's running on this
raspberry pi here which I have plugged
into the back of my telescope so by
doing that and having Mathematica look
up the coordinates of different
astronomical objects I can have it set
my telescope mount to point to those
objects and start tracking them what I'm
going to do is I'm going to have
mathematical look up several different
astronomical objects and then the scope
will Slough to that and then you could
either observe or take pictures so the
first thing I'm going to do is right now
the scope is in the park position we're
just kind of a neutral position but I'm
going to have it flew to the great
cluster in hercules and it's what is
doing right now is it's looking up the
coordinates for m3
which is great clustering Hercules and
its transmission to the amount
controller so now the scope is pointed
at m13 and Hercules so now I'm going to
so let's say I've taken some pictures or
observed it for a while now i'm going to
point it at the ring nebula so it's
looking up the coordinates of that and
it's sending them to the to the
telescope device
okay and now i'm going to point it to
m56 and it's looking up the coordinates
for that and it's a little lower object
right now of course this is during the
daytime so it's not going to be easy to
observe them and finally going to do m10
and the pause you're observing it is
it's looking up the data for this and
there's transmitted to the telescope
there's basically two different types of
telescope protocols that are widely and
used today there's the lx200 protocol
and the next our protocol and the
package I've written will use both of
those protocols to control almost all of
the consumer grade telescopes and
telescope mounts that are sold today
then when you're done you can tell
mathematica to to put the scope back
into the park position
and there goes so that's that would be a
complete observing session and you could
program it to automatically go through a
sequence of objects for instance one of
the things you might want to do with
this sort of control would be to
programmatically look for supernovas in
a bunch of different galaxies so you
could set up your Mathematica package to
have a list of galaxies that may or may
not have supernovas in them and then
through the course of the night it would
go to any one of the galaxies and the
sequence it would take a picture and
then proceed to the next galaxy and then
you could use image processing
techniques to see if there's a new star
in that galaxy people automate supernova
hunts this way all the time but this is
one way you could do it with Mathematica
now tomorrow we're going to actually
take this setup out into the field as it
were and try to get some pictures of the
moon or something like that so will when
I see you again we'll be back in the
field on the U of I campus you can see
me setting up the telescope I'm
inserting the pike am into the telescope
eyepiece holder that I'm connecting the
serial cable to control the mount and
there the pike am is instructing the
telescope to point towards the moon this
is all running in Mathematica on the
pike am there it is pointed at the moon
and here you can see it's just captured
an image of the moon you see the craters
down there in the lower right hand and
upper right-hand corners there you go
you